[Applaus]
ende früh um halb fünf höre ich eine
explosion
ich habe das nicht ernst enorm dachte
vielleicht hat jemand eine medaille
gewonnen und feiert laut
rechts von mir am eingang zur wohnung
nummer eins steht jemand er trägt eine
sturmhaube und schaut geradeaus
plötzlich sah ich um halb sechs im
fernsehen wie das fenster aufgerissen
wurde und da sah ich anbringen
unter ihnen eine frau wie gesagt ihm er
solle menschlich sein er antwortet die
juden sind auch nicht menschen neuen
moscheen
sie haben ihnen gefoltert schreckliche
bilder das kann man sich überhaupt nicht
vorstellen
dann hörten wir live im fernsehen
schüsse explosionen
wir sahen auch das feuer aus einem der
helikopter dann wurde es still
[Musik]
an die spitze am grab ihres ermordeten
mannes erschossen von palästinensischen
terroristen mitten in deutschland
ich komme seit 50 jahren hierher und der
schmerz ist noch immer der gleiche
am 5 september
1972 werden elf israelische athleten
während der olympischen spiele in
münchen
kaltblütig ermordet
fünf von ihnen sind auf diesem friedhof
in tel aviv begraben
hier ist ein davidstern und hier liegt
oper andré und tier sind seine freunde
meine enkelin ist fünf jahre alt sie
heißt nina sie kommt hierher und pflegt
die goldenen inschriften an den gräbern
grüße von oma dann hat sie ihr ohr auf
das grab gelegt und gesagt aber er
antwortet nicht
andere spitze antwortet seiner frau anni
seit 50 jahren nicht mehr um das
schweigen und die lehre zu ertragen
sucht an getrost bei elan romano
auch ihr mann wurde von den terroristen
in münchen ermordet
die katastrophe traf uns als 4 26
jährige junge frauen waren
anti hatte ein neugeborenes baby und ich
hatte drei töchter eine sechsjährige
eine vierjährige und eine war erst fünf
monate alt
es ist der fünfte september als
palästinensische terroristen brutal die
wohnungen nummer eins und drei in der
münchner koloniestraße 31 überfallen
hier wohnen israelische olympioniken ab
jetzt sind sie geiseln unter ihnen
gabalier ist israels meister im ringen
und die einzige geisel der die flucht
vor den terroristen gelingt
bild -chef reporterin antonia jamin
trifft dort in seinem kleinen restaurant
in tel aviv
ich sehe hier das erste bild ist von den
olympischen spielen
ja das ist der einzug ins stadion da
sind alle noch am leben danach ermordet
wurde
[Musik]
weitere spiele sollen es 1972 werden die
welt sollte sehen die olympiade unter
dem hakenkreuz
1936 sie ist geschichte
deutschland hat sich verändert
deutschland ist friedlich offen sicher
für alle
ich erinnere mich noch an die wachleute
dort die liefen nicht wie polizisten und
nicht bewaffnet die liefen herum wie
kellner auf der straße
[Musik]
ungehindert dringen die terroristen in
das wohngebäude der israelischen
delegation ein erster tatort ist die
wohnung nummer eins
in der früh um halb fünf ich eine
explosion
ich habe das nicht ernst genommen dachte
vielleicht hat jemand eine medaille
gewonnen und feiert laut
und so habe ich weiter geschlafen
die sechs israelischen sportler in
wohnung nummer eins sind nun geiseln die
terroristen stürmen weiter ihr nächstes
ziel wohnung nummer drei hier schlafen
geht zur bar und fünf seiner kameraden
nach 20 minuten hörte ich stimmen hinter
unserem zimmer also bin ich raus und da
stehe ich tatsächlich vor den
terroristen
das war es dann mit der weißen mütze
dann sah mich und richtete sofort die
kalaschnikow auf mich
den terroristen wohnung 3 wird schnell
klar sie brauchen dringend ihre
kriminellen komplizen sie zwingen die
jüdischen sportler aus dem raum der
erste von ihnen im korridor ist kabarett
mich hat es verrückt gemacht dass er die
kalaschnikow richtig in mich rein geburt
hat damit ich verstehe was er will damit
ich auf die andere seite gehen deshalb
habe ich mit einem schlag die
kalaschnikow von meinem bauch
weggeschlagen
[Musik]
bis heute ist die flucht in graz
gedächtnis präsent freundin die ihn im
restaurant besuchen erzählt er davon
dass es der zickzack zwischen den
pfeilern der terrorist ist hier ja und
ich rennen im zickzack nur in der
unterhose siehst du das ist nur einfluss
hat er auch sich geschossen als du
beckenrand bist ja aber er hat mich
nicht getroffen
auch in wohnung nummer zwei schlafen zu
diesem zeitpunkt israelische sportler
einer von ihnen ist schon adani hier hat
den holocaust überlebt bei den
olympischen spielen 1972 in münchen
entkommt er nur knapp dem tod
schau ist mehrfacher israelische
landesmeister im gehen
noch heute beginnt für ihn jeder tag mit
lauftraining
was machen wir jetzt wie viel laufen wir
fünf kilometer fünf kilometer es ist
sechs uhr morgens
eine stunde und fünf kilometer später
ist das training vorbei
all diese pokale gehören ihn weil diese
und es gibt noch viele andere die nicht
hier stehen ich schätze dass ich
ungefähr 800 pokale besitze preise für
schaue den großen sportler und
weltrekordhalter im gehen lange vor
seinen siegen 1941 schau ist fünf jahre
alt
überfällt nazi-deutschland jugoslawien
unverzüglich wollen sie das land
judenfrei haben
14 tage später wurden in belgrad bereits
plakat an hauswänden aufgehängt auf
denen alle juden aufgefordert wurden zu
einem bestimmten zeit an einem
bestimmten ort zu erscheinen im zweiten
absatz stand juden die den anweisungen
nicht folgen werden erschossen meine
eltern beschlossen zu fliehen und die
donau zu überqueren nach budapest
die familie ladanyi flüchtet nach ungarn
aber drei jahre später steht die iss vor
der tür die familie wird im viehwaggon
ins konzentrationslager bergen belsen
deportiert
das ist die baracke in der ich war und
da kann man ein teil des wachstums sehen
und das hakenkreuz
ist es nicht schwer für sie ich habe das
durchgemacht es ist teil meiner
geschichte
durch einen gefangenenaustausch werden
schauen und seine eltern freigelassen
dann führt der weg ins gelobte land
später besucht in israel die universität
startet er seine gier laufbahn
sie führt die 1972 zu den olympischen
spielen nach deutschland
ich hatte nationalstolz ich dachte wir
zeigen der welt und deutschland dass wir
obwohl sie versucht haben uns zu
eliminieren hier sind und in der lage
sind uns der ganzen welt auf dem
gleichen niveau wie alle welt sportler
zu stellen
warnt nicht das 28 jahre nach dem
holocaust juden in deutschland immer
noch nicht sicher sind am 5 september
1972 wird er aus dem schlaf gerissen
gegen halb sechs uhr morgens weckte man
mich und dann sagte mir man hat nie ein
sportler in der delegation ermordet ohne
viel nachzudenken steckte ich meine füße
in die sportschuhe ich bin immer noch im
pyjama aber geht zur haustür und öffne
sie ihn rechts von mir am eingang zur
wohnung nummer eins steht jemand er
trägt eine sturmhaube und schaut
geradeaus vor ihm stehen vier wachleute
des olympischen dorfes alle unbewaffnet
und in pastellfarbener kleidung unter
ihnen eine frau
sie bittet den maskierten im roten kreuz
zu erlauben einzutreten und jemanden zu
helfen sich sagte ihm er solle
menschlich sein er antwortet die juden
sind auch nicht menschlichen
aus angst auch als geisel genommen zu
werden fliehen scholz mitbewohner
schauwand noch den delegationsleiter in
wohnung nummer 5 zusammen entkommen sie
über den balkon
in wohnung nummer eins bricht das chaos
aus josef romano elenas ehemann war
israels meister im gewichtheben versucht
sich gegen die terroristen zu wehren
greift sie an mit einem obstmesser
die hätten ihn einfach erschießen können
aber was haben sie gemacht sie haben ihn
gefoltert schreckliche bilder das kann
man sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen
er hatte ein weißes t shirt an und der
ganze untere teil war in fetzen gerissen
um sieben uhr abends klopfte es an der
tür ein arzt und ein vertreter des
olympischen komitees sagten mir sie sei
schwer verletzt ich sagte deinen blick
nach zu urteilen ist es schlimmer dann
gab er zu jossi sei der zweite am orde
jersey erhaschen
[Musik]
in diesen stunden ist angeber ihren
eltern in den niederlanden verfolgt den
anschlag im fernsehen sie weiß bereits
dass ihr mann als geisel genommen wurde
plötzlich sah ich um halb sechs im
fernsehen wie das fenster aufgerissen
wurde und da sah ich an drehen
die behörden fragten ihn wie die
situation im zimmer sei also antwortete
er ihnen dass alle bis auf einen in
ordnung sein dann durfte er nicht weiter
reden und ich habe gesehen wie sie ihn
mit kalaschnikows ins zimmer geschoben
haben dann haben sie das fenster
geschlossen und den vorhang zugezogen
das war das letzte mal dass ich ihn
gesehen habe
die deutschen behörden lassen sich zum
verhandeln drängen die terroristen
dürfen mit neuen jüdischen geiseln
aufbrechen das ziel der flughafen
fürstenfeldbruck
ich sagte meiner mutter das ist jetzt
ihr ende sie wollen die geiseln aus dem
fokus der welt nehmen und die deutschen
interessieren sich überhaupt nicht für
sie sind es nur elf weitere juden die
auf deutschem boden sterben werden
deutsche sicherheitskräfte starten eine
rettungsaktion
sie versagen
diese arroganz der deutschen die
demütigende haltung immer hin wollte
israel eine spezialeinheit schicken um
einen rettungsversuch zu unternehmen
deutschland hat nein gesagt auf keinen
fall wir wissen was wir tun was habt ihr
denn genau getan ihr habt noch nicht mal
einen gerettet nicht einmal
im flugzeug das die terroristen fordern
sitzen deutsche polizisten verkleidet
als piloten ihnen wird es zu gefährlich
sie fliehen im tower sind deutsche
scharfschützen postiert ihre waffen
veraltet
danach leistelle sie dann hörten wir
live im fernsehen schüsse explosionen
wir sahen auch das feuer aus einem der
helikopter dann wurde es still und dann
hörten wir wieder schwache cottbuser j
der hubschrauber explodiert die deutsche
feuerwehr steckt in münchen im stau der
einzige noch lebende israelische athlet
stirbt an den folgen einer
rauchvergiftung
ein viertel nach drei am morgen sahen
wir plötzlich jay kay den bbc moderator
mit der gelben jacke er sagte heute
morgen waren die elf israelis noch am
leben doch zwei seien im olympischen
dorf ermordet worden und neun weitere am
flughafen
in dieser nacht ist an die bereits auf
dem weg nach münchen die junge witwe
geht in das zimmer in dem ihr mann seine
letzten stunden durchlitten hat
bis heute ist es schwer und schmerzhaft
für mich zu beschreiben was ich dort
gesehen habe das blut war überall im
raum sogar an der decke da wo sie ihn
erschossen haben ist die hälfte der wand
runter gefahren ab doch arbeit doch gäbe
[Musik]
die israelische botschaft in deutschland
hat nachgefragt ob die olympischen
spiele jetzt gestoppt werden sie
erhalten ein antwort telegramm die
olympischen spiele werden nicht gestoppt
sonst haben die tv sender nichts zum
ausstrahlen stellen sie sich das mal vor
elf menschen wurden ermordet ihr blut
ist noch nichtmal getrocknet und
deutschland sagt mir dass es den
sponsoren etwas schuldet und dass das
land sonst nichts hat was es im
fernsehen zeigen kann
[Musik]
die sportler kehre nach hause zurück elf
von ihnen in särgen für schaut eine kaum
zu ertragen niederlage den notar
arabische länder haben jahrelang
versucht uns von allen möglichen sport
foren auszuschließen und hier nachdem
sie unser blut vergossen befriedigen wir
unsere feinde und verlassen das
olympische forum und verschwinden
aber damit ist der horror nicht zu ende
die behörden in deutschland weigern sich
die verantwortung für die vielen fehler
ihrer gescheiterten rettungsaktionen zu
übernehmen die akten sind in
verschiedenen archiven vergraben den
witwen wird der zugang verweigert
manfred schreiber der präsident der
münchner polizei er sagte mir ihr habt
den terror nach deutschland gebracht sie
sprechen von terroristen aber das waren
freiheitskämpfer und
dann der nächste große schock mit einer
flugzeug entführung werden die drei
überlebenden terroristen freigepresst
vor ein deutsches gericht kommen sie
und ich zwei junge mädchen hören
plötzlich nach zwei monaten dass ein
flugzeug entführt wurde und dass man die
terroristen freigibt ich sage anke das
kann doch nicht wahr sein das ist doch
total fabriziert angesagte mir ja du
hast bestimmt recht aber das musst du
erstmal beweisen
die zwei witwen erzählen von zahlreichen
ungereimtheiten bei der entführung der
lufthansa maschine lh
615 sie startet am 29 oktober
1972 in beirut an bord nur elf
passagiere alles männer außer den
stewardessen die forderung der entführer
die freilassung der drei münchen
attentäter dann geht es schnell die
terroristen werden nach tripolis
ausgeflogen
dort präsentieren sie sich dreist der
welt geben eine pressekonferenz was die
welt nicht weiß findet sich in einem
dokument des britischen nationalarchiv
danach hatte der britische botschafter
1972 seinem außenministerium brisantes
zu melden die deutschen hatten vorab
kenntnis davon dass am 30 oktober etwas
passieren würde und weiter in tripolis
hatte man seit 15 tagen auf die
entführung der lufthansa-maschine
gewartet
sie wollten sie loswerden weil sie einen
deal mit allen möglichen arabischen
terrororganisationen machen wollten
damit es keine terroranschläge mehr in
deutschland gehabt jahre später
behauptet abu dawud der drahtzieher des
münchner olympia attentat in seiner
biografie dass die deutschen nach dem
olympia attentat auf ihn zugekommen
seien um die freipressung zu arrangieren
dafür seien ihm neun millionen dollar
angeboten worden
sie haben uns betrogen die dachten die
witwen gehen stehen nach hause und
ziehen ihre kinder groß wir haben unsere
kinder zu ruhm erzogen und wir haben
auch weiter gekämpft ich versichere
ihnen der fleck auf der deutschen weste
wird noch viele viele jahre bleiben
monarchie
bis heute gibt es keinen eindeutigen
beweis dafür dass die flugzeugentführung
tatsächlich arrangiert wurde klar aber
ist dass vor 50 jahren viel zu viel
schief ging vor und während des
attentats aber auch danach
[Musik]